When it comes to getting clicks on the
internet or selling newspapers, there's
an old saying, if it bleeds, it leads.
Which means if bad news is coming, if
you can report on bad news, do it
because it gets you clicks, gets you
intention, gets you sold newspapers.
That's fine. Nothing wrong with that.
But the reality is sometimes a bit more
nuanced. And today I want to have on the
show Steven Halberg, one of the leading
experts and leading historians of all
time when it comes to our Second
Amendment right to keeping arms. He has
written countless books on everything
from the disarmament of the Jews in
Germany that led to the Holocaust to
stories about the importance of arms in
Switzerland to of course many major
Second Amendment related books including
a detailed history of the AR-15 which he
calls America's rifle and the right to
keep and bear arms. And keep in mind
that Stephen Halbrook, in addition to
being an author of the long-standing
important firearms law desk book, which
every practicing gun lawyer has on his
desk, in addition to all that, he also,
of course, has been cited to none other
than Justice Anthony Scalia in that case
you may have heard of, DC versus Heler.
Today I talked to Stephen about is he
optimistic or pessimistic about the
future of the Second Amendment since
he's been doing gun related stuff since
the 1970s. And remember, we all have to
remember we're in a war, folks. We're
not in a battle. There's lots and lots
of battles that go into the war we're
in. And there are going to be some good
days, there's going to be some bad days.
And we just have to keep that in mind.
And there's certainly a lot of bad news
out there. If you look at what's going
on in those states that the Democrats
control with a trifecta, they control
the governor's mansion. They control the
courts. They control the legislature.
States like, I don't know, Washington,
California, uh, Illinois, Virginia, New
Mexico, Colorado, uh, New Jersey, New
York, and so on. There's a lot of
evidence that there's problems, but the
reality is all that anti-gun money has
to be filtered and funneled in to those
terrible anti-gun states because they're
not accomplishing anything at the
federal level. They're not actually
accomplishing that much in the federal
courts. And of course, we know they're
doing nothing in the states where the
Republicans are generally in control. So
they focus their attention on a handful
of states, but there is a lot of bad
news out there in the paper. So I talked
to Steven Hbrook today about, hey, what
do you think about the future of the
Second Amendment? How far have we come?
Where's the future look like? And should
we be optimistic or pessimistic about
the right to keep him bear arms in
America? So without further ado, here is
Mark Smith and Steven Halbert talking
about the future of the Second
Amendment. check it out. Now, you've
been involved in the Second Amendment
community working on Second Amendment
and gunrelated issues since, you know,
the 1970s or so. Uh, a lot of people uh
get frustrated with the Trump
administration or the speed at which the
Supreme Court moves. Uh, I understand
all those concerns and I feel it. I feel
the pain myself, frankly. Um but but
with that said, can you talk a little
bit about why we should be optimistic
for the future of the right to keep and
bear arms in America and and how far
we've come because I think people don't
realize it was in many people's
lifetimes uh that we we did not even
have a Supreme Court that recognized the
right to keep and bear arms, never mind
a series of cases in our favor. So can
you talk a little bit about why people
and the viewers here should be
optimistic about the future of the
Second Amendment, how far we really have
come, even though of course we always
want to move faster.
Right. I mean, we live in a a much
better world in the Second Amendment
space. If you go back to the 60s, you
have the the drive for radical gun
control. Fortunately, Congress didn't
enact some of the most radical
provisions that were being um uh put
forth like regist comprehensive
registration.
um you have uh the Gun Control Act of 68
and then a lot of state laws being
enacted and then you have ATF coming on
the scene and and going hog wild and
under the Carter administration and um
violating people's rights to keep and
bear arms and and then you have um the
Reagan administration comes in and we
have firearms owners protection act and
that was quite a a title wave of of good
things happening under the second amend
amendment. Um, but nonetheless, you
still had um ATF doing pretty much what
they wanted to do. And and and once
again, the the court's not saying
anything
except making things up like, well, the
Second Amendment creates a collective
militia right and doesn't protect any
individual right to keep and bear arms.
And so finally we get to um there was a
good fifth circuit decision called
Emerson leading up to Heler and then we
get Heler and um and but we still in a
lot of those years no matter who was
president we didn't have much um of an
agenda to really take an aggressive
approach to supporting the Second
Amendment.
You know, with the first Trump
administration, I think we had high
hopes, but we we had so much distraction
there with all the Russia hoax and
everything else that was going on. Uh
there was not so much that could be
done, although you had some good things
happening like the uh rules against
agencies
um making statements that were their
policies and enforceable by law.
um you you had regulations against that,
but but then we end up with with the
Biden administration and ATF going out
of control and and I think a lot of
people in ATF didn't like it even um you
had the
uh [clears throat]
no mercy rule. Basically, if you if
you're a dealer and you have a one
violation even inadvertent
that um your license could be yanked and
um you have the attempt to extend the
definition of firearm through
regulations and one thing after another.
I I think this administration has done a
wonderful job. It's not perfect. Uh but
I'm very optimistic. We we've got
lawsuits filed against the DC so-called
assault weapon ban. We have um ATF being
told that its policies have to be
changed. We have some we have a second
amendment scholar as the chief counsel
at ATF, Robert Lighter. Um there's a lot
of support for the acting director.
We'll see what the Senate does with
that. But um
I mean ATF has a
a legal duty to enforce the Gun Control
Act. We we hope it won't enforce it in
an overly aggressive way, but there's
provisions of the Gun Control Act that
are just not good and ought to be looked
at again. But I think if you want to
compare the way it is now with the way
it was in the 60s and and 70s, I have to
say I went to law school in the 70s and
there was no mention of the Second
Amendment, but the student newspaper had
anti-gun articles in it. Um, so we've
gone a long way. We've got the
Federalist Society. We have Second
Amendment courses being taught in a
number of law schools. And so, you know,
if if you want to complain about today,
look, at least it's a big improvement.
And look back at how far we've gone.
>> Yeah. I mean, in the 1970s, we did not
have the Helder decision that says you
have a right that it's an individual
right to keep. You did not have the
Brewan decision that says you have a
right to carry a gun in public for
self-defense. We never won cases. It
seemed like they were very rare. And
now, uh, at least we have a fighting
chance to win a lot of cases. And as you
know, a lot of the cases we do lose,
frankly, it's because they're in
terrible jurisdiction with terrible
judges that just rubber stamp what the
government wants. Uh, the Harvey
Wilkinsons of the Fourth Circuit, uh,
the usual suspects in Boston in the
First Circuit, the Ninth Circuit on Bond
Games. Uh, but the good news is, uh,
people now understand what's going on. I
think there was a lot of uh basically uh
uh people in the dark with the realities
of the court system, the Second
Amendment, how it was interpreted, how
it was applied. And I think there's a
lot more sunlight out there, a lot more
transparency. So even if we in the
Second Amendment community don't like
what's going on, we at least know what's
going on and understand how it's
happening. And if you don't diagnose the
problem correctly, you can never fix it
as we all well know. So, Stephen
Halbrook, is there any final thoughts?
Uh, anything else you want to add,
Stephen? Anything you're doing or that
we should pay attention to or any final
thoughts you want to share with the
Second Amendment community here?
>> Well, um, I regularly post my bullet
conspiracy pieces on my website and
other new articles that come out,
stephvenhalberg.com.
uh my two latest books, the right to
bear arms,
a constitutional right of the people or
privilege of the ruling class and the
second one is the AR-15.
Uh I'm sorry, America's rifle, the case
for the AR-15.
Uh I think those are good books for our
current issues and I would recommend
them and um ju just keep in touch.
There's a lot going on. Um, nowadays you
get to listen to Supreme Court cases
being argued and you don't have to be a
lawyer to enjoy listening to some of
those cases. So, um, there's I'm just so
much more optimistic now than the way
things used to be and we we hope it'll
continue that way. We shall see.
>> Great. Well, Stephen Habrick, thank you
so much for joining us here at the
Forbox Diner. It's always a pleasure.
I'm sure we'll have you back on at some
point in the next several months. And
again, uh, it'll be interesting to see
what happens over the next, uh, the rest
of the year with the Trump
administration, the midterms, all the
Supreme Court cases. So, I do think the
trend is our friend, but we have a lot
of work to do and I think we're going to
do the work we need to do to win for our
rights. So, again, Stephen Habrick,
thank you for coming in again.
>> Thank you, Mark. My my pleasure. Take
care.
>> Orders up. Table 2A. [music]